we're trying to make us an educational
experience but I'm mostly drinking same
Ryan same I like to drink gin and soda a
little bit of lime except I'm lying
about the soda part it's straight gin I
just say soda so people don't worry
about me Ryan Reynolds was a whole damn
mood during a video chat with Stephen
Colbert for The Late Show on Wednesday
revealing how he and his wife Blake
Lively along with their three daughters
are social distancing amid the ongoing
coronavirus outbreaks
I do not miss masculine company at all
really most most you know men tend to
just be the architects of someone's
demise so it's fine I like just being
here with the girls I like doing the
girl stuff I like you know like I try
not to push sort of gender normative
ideas on my kids as they were born but
each one when they came out that shoot
they were just they really wanted to
make dresses they wanted to dress in hot
pink all day so that's what I do I'm
this morning I made a dress this out of
tissue paper this is what we're doing
we're developing the skills that are
gonna take us into the new world yeah
and they're keeping busy with all of
your run-of-the-mill quarantine
activities oh boy we are doing a lot of
homeschooling we're doing uh we're lucky
enough to have a little tiny garden so
we're learning a little bit about
gardening we're trying to make us an
educational experience but I'm mostly
drinking oh and did I mention Blake's
mom is quarantine with them too and my
mother-in-law here is way she's also
there which is really she's been a
lifesaver
it's been incredible to have her here
and I she doesn't know it but she's
actually she's emergency food if this
gets real walk out grandma lively oh no
fun we're best friends as for Blake
she's making sure Ryan keeps it looking
fresh even if they are locked up at the
house tomorrow
Blake is gonna is gonna give me a
haircut she's done this once before yeah
it's a two and a half hours and and then
at the end it looked like she'd done the
whole thing using only a lighter or like
or like those you know those gloves that
are made of sandpaper it would have been
a little faster my she just wore it down
look she just rubs my head until the
hair just disappeared so tomorrow we're
gonna
haircut very excited and just when I
thought that I couldn't possibly love
them more get this guy's Ryan and Blake
have donated 1 million dollars to food
banks in Canada and the US as well as
$400,000 to New York City hospitals and
Ryan's gin label aviation also pledged a
percentage of sales to help out-of-work
bartenders who have been hit hard by the
social distancing guidelines I'm not
really in the business of telling people
what to do necessarily but I do think
it's incumbent upon me you know those
who can get back to do so particularly
in a time like this
[Music]